[Music]
hello truth nation her [__] hold some
problem please monitors like a rockstar
you're not actually supposed to do that
poor Steve that's the problem nurse the
thing is if you sing about it you're
supposed to have done it you know we
went to a beaver where's that basically
I'm worried about poor some alone really
you've never been worried about postman
I've always have to do because you don't
have to you not to worry about him stop
worrying about post Malone here's a
massive talent he's very young he's
gotten very rich very quickly very quick
and sometimes some people just don't
deal with that now we've noticed all of
the face towels there's clearly I feel
like issues there that he's sort of
voicing through his face type news the
guy was a perfectly handsome lad I know
that face tattoos are in fashion but to
that degree
yeah he looks like my old desk at school
what's wrong it why is it one having a
go at a guy who's got face tattoos just
to take some drugs just it's getting to
the point where I think there's some
issues that he's got right and maybe I'm
wrong maybe it's not the face that booze
but the [__] is when you combine that
with the photo just come out look at his
look at his eyes there he looks like
he's possessed me yeah that's the act
that's not a knock door Laurence are we
worried about him then
well I he's literal biggest song that we
all rewarded and when yeah that's good
he talks about hoes Pili's which I'm
assuming means drugs and living like a
rock star
and everyone went [__] love it made
and then when he's living that way they
go whoa whoa whoa you're not support
just make just sing about you know this
is the thing though it's like when
rappers wrote about killing people it
sounds good
you don't actually do it Terry isn't it
it's jihad movements as well they're
they're really odd his face just looks
so like inflated by yeah you don't owe
me a drink and his hair look at the hair
it's very my house Cesc and that's
that's the thing from you don't lose
another another that I could so you've
done some amazing songs you know I mean
yeah and then that weird one ways the
microphones on the floor he sort of
picking it up and he's oh it's like a
dead bird like it's a little bird and
then a bit like it's a [__] so it did
look like for a second he was treating
it gently and then suddenly went that's
a big shaft and everyone's like whoa
don't dawn and then he does this thing
with his hand afterwards
swish it's it's not a swish how's it
it's not is he drunk
just drunk see I don't think this is
just drunk nothing that's why everyone's
concerned rockers we've all been drunk
it's fun it's good time it can be bit
long as you don't drink to excess drink
just make you do that
there's things he did this the way his
eyes are moving like he's clearly on
drugs yeah and so anything is we're not
surprised when it starts affecting you
in public that regularly it's got a hold
of you yeah that's the point way
everyone's going now you're taking the
piss with it me and now you need to stop
before it controls you you know is what
happens to a lot I'm certainly not
sitting a gun odds all right as long as
you do it a little bit but the point is
is it could [__] end in disaster this
in a similar a nice yeah we don't want
it yeah like you know people miss Amy
Winehouse up much and this guy since
streaming records be garden the two of
his albums are top five ever since the
streaming something like that I've seen
the other day Drake was like number one
by a long way yes scorpion is him yeah
it was scorpion it yeah and then to pour
subs are in the top five
yeah so it's like this is a modern-day
legend a guy as well who you'd imagine
is quite powerful millions of that so
telling him hey well don't take those
traces all you that drink he goes I'll
do what I want so like when you're on
that level you need people to tell you
what what are you [__] doing and like
this is where you find out they're
usually surrounded by yes men oh you can
go out on stage and that state it's
beyond me but people argue it's a bit of
an act they are gets part of it no no I
like it do not know but this is like
Jenny one who's sitting there go nuts
enough I've said many live shows with
this guy many and he clearly like
support you yeah but this is a new level
I mean how often you see ever see a
celebrity ever in that state you know
variated to that let out of it you're
dressed at a concert apartment
these have given up drugs or I'm on
drugs said I'm not on drugs right here
the person felt my life okay it does
worry not the most convincing denial
I've ever seen in my life like no but I
feel [__] fantastic he might be
telling the truth if that might have all
been enough it doesn't look like it was
enough you know I mean the most powerful
people with the most extreme lifestyles
will have extremes and I don't know if
we can expect post Malone to live within
the normal boundaries a lot of people do
he's not even the normal loafers what
would you do if you are on post Malone
that's the problem how do you reach out
you the record label AUV you know you
the people around mg do the people
around him even think this is unhealthy
do they go that's just a couple of
nights you know every now and again he
does some druggies he needs someone to
grab grab em and go you sit at the [__]
dough and you need to calm yourself what
if you have someone around him who
thinks [__] this is his creative process
what if I interrupt this and he becomes
a lot of sport obviously poor forever
they need it for them do you know the
most common thing I've heard it's common
to do when you get high yeah is to keep
checking your Twitter and social media
accounts yeah because you think did I
post something absolutely sure I post
yeah I just post a selfie with it
constantly checking social media like
I'm pretty sure I've just posted some
ink when I've been like dropping off
yeah which is what you've been hold ya
told so when you've been falling asleep
you are the public I'm just not not
asleep I've heard yeah they keep
thinking they're porcelain yeah yeah
yeah so you're telling me that when
other people get higher their check your
social media when you're falling asleep
right yeah next time you get high if you
do in a legal country
don't be checking true Jordi's social
media don't be posting anything that's
the point because really you could make
yourself look strip free in mind in
other ways meditate
psychedelic speaking of someone else who
feels that their life is slightly out of
control may need to address it publicly
this week she linked by them yeah this
week Shan doctor and stop me saying it
was it was on a roll this week Shane
Dawson addressed my weight his weight
gain is that Shane Dawson do yeah that
was him listen I don't feel like it's
the weight gain
to address you know how that fellow's
made twist of the wick of the way Cody
Kruger was a Freddy Jeffrey Jeffrey I
knew it was a typical English name but
didn't look anything like the identity
the man has woman person there is
something else they have overseen this
week it involves someone leading a comma
to simply say we have about his body and
it way can we just say them someone
shamed him about this body way on a
comment welcomes our without news no
sorry that's that's an hourly basis for
me and in real life during a screenshot
of a common read a love scene but it's a
damn shame to watch him putting all this
weight back on while everyone around him
laughs and enables it enables it so how
people look at you when I'm not in the
room did this anything like you from it
are you gonna let him keep eating like
that you cannot allow that are you gonna
keep ordering that I don't order it
sometimes you do order it yeah but gia
goes she really beaten ate Perkis in a
row he's not eating ate don't worry if
you're worried about there this isn't
you don't have to have an intervention
no one is to intervene he's fine
perfectly happy yeah I've never feel
fantastic
then tell me Brian why are you trying to
hide your body with camo
I love you so much saying I'm so sorry
you had to see that comment hey why
don't we just not leave horribly abusive
comments on people's video this is the
thing no some of them are actually
leaving comments in in worry for him you
don't have a heart attack or something
if you really care about someone sure
that's fine it's difficult to tell
online what your tone is whether
someone's happy or whether someone's sad
whether someone's caring or someone's
nasty emojis help with that right so if
you're telling me I'm a fat [__] you
put a heart on the end I might forgive
you especially if you're a woman he'll
definitely forgive you because sometimes
girls are treated mr. further than the
past yeah I like a Big Daddy
there's a little bit of miracles or she
shamed me there really how to me feel
when you're shamed by a woman I'll allow
it
yeah you can do gone ladies so because
you get an erection because of a comment
it's alright in a word Laurence
absolutely right
we literally [__] you you're gonna die
soon I know it I can feel it I'm psychic
it's probably made worse by the fact
that his boyfriend is in considerably
better shape than him when you're a man
and a woman generally speaking the
woman's always the pretty one go with me
on this
the woman's always the pretty one I mean
that's the way it's supposed to be and
indeed if something to say right you
know I'm pretty yeah I'm pretty pretty
good yeah what should see that ass table
book but the thing is squat bootie but
the thing is when those two fellas walk
into a bedroom together they're gonna
kind of compare a man and a woman yep
you're so different I never never look
at a woman and go yeah I'm in better
shape than you we're totally different
we look different Christ I'm a 23 stone
mark my tits are much smaller than yours
she says with these two fellas they walk
into a bedroom they can literally look
gold well I can see my dick my belly's
smaller than his right but he's got a
bigger [__] so swings and roundabouts
isn't it I suppose that's position maybe
it does do you not think maybe it's
partner like someone who's a little bit
yeah all I'm saying is if I was a gay
fella it might make me feel if I was a
gay fun we're not gay and we can't be
clear about that we neither of us can
worry about Germany and you look at my
body you do like trim yeah he's pretty
trivial it's all right babe I like him a
bit thick anyway I love you
and then we'd snog tongues and all
tongue but you're sickening about that
in your heads is that what you're
thinking about no we planted that little
seed in your mind of us kissing does
that make you gay I think that's what
you'd like isn't it that makes you gay
told you fondly Tommy I watched true
news it made me gay and we're also
worried about true Jordi's waking at
what point when you're the pub when
you're in the public eye come to people
not common about you and why is it okay
for people to give positive comments but
not necessarily comment on something
which seems quite obvious because he has
gained weight so the reality is that
Shane has gained well done by dancing
Shane is saying that as he change you're
saying I don't really want to hear it
I'm just gonna take it for you which is
fair and that's fair enough but at the
same time does that mean that people
should not comment because
doesn't make him feel good I think this
is the thing noise that's the balance
that we're all trying to find online
nowadays so back in the day when there
was no social media generally you only
compared yourself to your mates yeah and
you who you went to the pub with or
whatever now it's just bombarded into
our faces like obviously we see in
advertising and TV back in the day but
now everyone's [__] body is all over
Facebook and Instagram and Twitter and
everywhere and you're saying you're
being hit with all these images and
you're left sort of knowing where you
are in the pecking order a lot more do
you care about 'we are in the pecking
order it's always want to feel good
about themselves he's normal he isn't
feeling good because he's being directly
told yeah you're our [__] and he
probably knew that anybody Jim I mean
this isn't a surprise there in the
comments again you look great yeah let's
turn that off all those Snickers no I
really thought weren't having an impasse
whom you've shot that's mean that's
faction no but this is the thing though
this is what I'm trying to say Shane is
a realist everything about him seems to
be self-aware although he's a drama
queen he knows what he's doing I don't
think he's trying to fight the system
he's well aware of the system he's in
yeah in eat food wait he's trying to get
people to get off his back and away his
tight little ass goes wow that's a bit
weird as ice does anyone really drink
water like that does he need to show us
up also do unique I feel like eating
rabbit eel do its job you know they put
subliminal messages in like movies I
feel like we're getting targeted yeah a
subliminal message you you getting I'm
feeling thirsty are you gonna a big
bottle Shane
you can take a bigger load than me oh
you're the better man of water
right a lot thank you and I think
because I'm strong right very I do
wouldn't done how's he paid of actress
to come and say all this is she just
like a fit actress who isn't really a
trainer at you and write anything yeah
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be straight with
the air Brian I think you'll be cheaper
to get a real trainer than an actress
when you're in America so be easier for
him to be a trainer that day and go come
and train me and just when I bring a
camera crew over what do sing was
because we didn't actually see any
exercise that all we've seen was him
finishing a raw egos 100 is my bad that
was fat shaming I assumed it was cake I
assumed it was Kay well it wasn't as me
so kinda didn't pigs are not good
branded under like Lawrence tomorrow I'm
gonna release a line of pigs on t-shirts
I go p-- right fine that's no good I hit
their perfect bull because they're like
quite sort of pardoning him quite sort
of why does it pig fun but he's got
quite a pink face do you know no man do
you not think he's got like a pink fit
he has a pink complexion because white
man these particularly pig you're quite
pale by yes person I'm Casper the [__]
Friendly Ghost he's got a big lord yeah
this yeah this guy's the Barry's worried
someone's gonna come along and blow his
house down yeah it shames contact is
good but I just feel like I would I'd
like to just trim it right down to 10
minutes
fashioned from about you could just trim
down please Shane sorry I didn't mean it
doesn't seem nice
now we've done the important stuff
alright undo the lighter stuff under the
less importance of trivial matters we do
that untrue news of names
yes the coronavirus I thought a beer
could cause so much uproar you know
they've lost loads of money the seals
are don't make sense people getting a
bit angry at the word it's just word
association in your head when you when
you've gone to a bar and the baby
sitting on the hood coronavirus corona
but people die in like over and over and
over again you got a bar and you go
and I have the dead drink naturally and
I think it's affecting sale never as a
man filled me with less confidence that
he's dealing with the coronavirus wealth
and Donald Trump a man who basically
just continues to repeat some absolute
[__] for about five minutes the same
number a lot of people are getting
better very much better very much better
much better the 15 people likewise we
have them down to a much lower number
they're in good shape Buster's ever
really good Church Shane Dawson said
they go to Fox's even the throne of I
may imagine if there was a fire and
someone went his fire out you went it's
going out it's there well yeah but what
kind of shapes in well we've got the
extinguishers yeah and we're about to
switch them on yeah we've got some
really great extinguishers really good
extinguisher see a fire brigade are on
the way yeah they're close I mean it's
definitely on the way I'll be honest
with you I've got called them yet I'm
going yeah I mean the process of I'm on
hold so what I love is he's clearly been
told to address that one person who
wasn't particularly good all right okay
he's not good hopefully I wouldn't say
not doing well but she is very sick but
she's hopefully getting no it's like
he's you know I've never seen someone
clearly just grasping at any positive it
you know it's really brilliant because
he also it's clearly like he's been
given a set of words he can't say in
defensive Trump he is doing the opposite
of the British media right he is trying
to calm people down right she's actually
a good thing they don't give them false
Kampf okay
I yeah you don't want to start planning
the British people someone sneezes we're
all gonna die we all put a bucket on
that it's like oh my god BBC and that
they literally got everyone thinking
that's it honestly I love about is
people dying around the world and he's
trying to claim credit for doing
everything about
trouble is that he views everything as a
competition with other countries yeah
well we're better than them we've only
got 50 yeah it down yeah inevitably
those numbers will start skyrocketing
because this thing is going to take
although it's gonna get around yeah
we're we're infectious little bastards
on this block yeah so is he gonna just
keep saying yet 50/50 in the whole time
that's what just 15 mr. Trump we've
confirmed cases that there were now in
the fifteen thousand what was said 15 17
said you can't get me on a technicality
I did say 15 I might have said of silent
key we have great talent great doctors
imagine they go be clear be concise and
make sure that you know you look like
you're in control you know who's on top
of this great we've gone really show
cific quit everyone great everyone
obviously fantastic all things good
imagine Donald Trump got it that would
be a twist wouldn't it well I mean
everyone's great I'm dying better than
the other people oh yeah there's a lot
of worry that's sporting events and just
public events in general are gonna be
called off because we kind of people
gathering public together sharing the
germs so the alternative yeah this is
where we come in live-streaming really
okay so specifically they're going to
start live streaming funerals really a
know which means you could have the dead
off you could now stream your funeral
with us we could react to it just as the
coffins going in Margaret was behind oh
yeah she's gone yeah talk a lot q is he
going this guy this guy we're gonna be
charging for those so if you want us to
react to your funeral you need to book
now let us know in the comments below
yeah we'll get but you're gonna need to
book early because I get the feeling
these are gonna be flying out what once
once people start dropping thick and
fast we're gonna need to be on that yeah
I mean we could be doing 10 a day yeah
minimum
I've always loved the speech I'd love to
be the one who gives the speech or them
yeah Tommy enough are if it so you
basically just go I really loved
well that's visit even you know the man
thing that's what the victors
I always think that so most of these
drama of channels that they do the
research they get all the clips they put
it all together why do we need to that
these are dinner for were scarce did a
little video on this guy basically there
was a live stream ah I don't know what
the [__] he was thinking but he's pissed
farting around with he's gone like he's
grown up and he shot it in his house and
now they've banned him another thing was
he is like a courier live stream every
day I've been doing on Twitch for five
years he seems to have done this by
mistake but they're just like now you've
got a girl he's been sucked from you
know they have clans
he's been suck but it's all I can go in
one shop if you had one shot one
opportunity to [__] up your clan
yeah he's [__] is this guy in our
first story it today comes from the
youtuber and trimmer known as Karl this
is just a call call yeah yeah that's a
bit of a I don't know what anything wise
it's not strong not but I don't know why
because like we're so used to no
youtubers having like a Vic star yeah
something that's got a bit of weird yeah
yeah like Carl gasps did you see I ain't
got money say got money
goddamn my god this is why guns should
not be allowed do you think he did that
deliberately or that was an accident we
take a look at his face and see he looks
a little bit fazed by that I don't know
some way they've gotten rid of him
though he just so what he's basically
only is he can't control his gun problem
well you know it's not the best
impression to put forward that you reach
a dour Bob dick although he didn't show
his dick off port like it could have
been bad it was on his way there's
animals warden around in the back of his
shot the cab you're not supposed to just
shoot they've gone off on a live stream
or I don't even know if you meant to
have a gun on lives it's really one of
those things you go make sure the guns
are not on the live stream
I mean you conceal your firearm my
weapon yeah you just wrap it around your
leg team then said he lost his
girlfriend his twitch partnership and he
was kicked from his team all in one
stream I have to say here that's a blaze
of glory though if you're gonna [__]
your life up you did it in one second I
made my biggest mistake of my entire
life last night and it could ruin my
life I just want to thanks or I have
nothing but love for those people and
they did what they needed to do because
I'm an idiot you know the guy feels
destroyed he says he's ruined his life
what I would say is try and not score
mentally down that road you know because
if he feels like his whole [__]
world's ended that could be bad for him
mentally we don't want him you know you
still got a way about you sly stream on
YouTube don't shoot you good off again
obviously the guns taken away now yeah
you lose your gun when you do that I
[Music]
don't know in America it's funny you
know it takes a lot looser code in
America after that you should lose the
gun yeah you know you know when you
crash into someone with a car and you
kill them or you crash in some people go
probably shouldn't do that yeah you see
I've I've had people crushing me and
they're fine but they shouldn't doesn't
work that way I should you know
genuinely right I was driving behind
some money on the deer I seen them go
the wrong way around around about I
couldn't [__] believe it
yeah he went on to the wrong just went
up up the wrong way I'm like I got a
look at him who's like an 8 year old man
I'm like what the [__] do I do here like
what do I do to stop this these guys
flash the lights
pull him over and just shoot you again
yeah I feel bad for this kid because
even though that was a dumbass thing to
do he said I'm just a [__] idiot like
it's like are you've done a bad thing
you've obviously got something about
you've done well with you sell you got
your solvent gay
and crew and all don't beat yourself up
too much yeah just won't shoot yourself
up you know this next clip maybe the
best thing on TV this year john fury big
jon few though yeah you had him in the
podcast really good guys a massive mark
like a mountain of a man yeah he watched
his son from afar he couldn't be in the
country in las vegas win the heavyweight
title the world couldn't be there
because of a previous conviction right
so I would to get on the play but that
almost adds to the mystique of the man
celebrates yeah each punch Tyson Fury
lungs II say that's what's come out of
these balls it's a good moment it's good
moment it's good map moment imagine a
moment where you're watching what's come
out of your ball your sperm become
heavyweight champion of the world I mean
obviously there was an egg involved yeah
I mean possibly we don't even know of it
all he was just sort of you just shot
him up doings and he just came out full
I said yeah no I won't put it beyond
John theory to have given birth if
there's a man tough enough to yeah
pretty angry but I'm also gonna push
hard what's your favorite out of context
John fury moment is it this shape to
yourselves your political bastards is
that one that one okay bang on the floor
end of give me none built what we are
stolen yeah bomb where's Tyson get it
you really are so like Tyson
you know I really love his people go
Tyson is one of one he's one of a kind
know you've never seen anything like
Tyson you look at his dad and you go to
have a kind face or life is kind of
anything I think I'd rather fight iczer
than even he looks scarier than Tyson
speaking of Tyson the other Tyson now
have you heard about his daughter I'm
purely showing this for context of the
news story yeah Mike Tyson's daughter
who is to my knowledge and happily in a
relationship
there was a jockey sort of thing going
around where someone suggested my Tyson
was willing to pay someone ten million
dollars to marry his daughter comedian
Mike
Blackson yeah took it upon himself to DM
mike directly and offer his hand in
marriage right so he replies to the news
story about my Tyson's daughter that
isn't real
yeah if this is true he said to Mike I
think I'm finally ready to settle down
good to know I've been dipping and
dabbing in a few snow bunnies an Asian
persuasion but I'm ready for your
beautiful Queen I'm ready to give you
some grandkids that will have the
complexion of Tyson Bedford knowledge of
Cicely Tyson top like you Mike Tyson and
hopefully not built like Tyson Fury I
really don't give a [__] about the money
but I'll take it
waiting to hear from you father-in-law
said he genuinely DMD but Mike responded
this is the thing I think you should
probably because if I say it might sound
like I'm actually saying why would you
care if I said when you read things it's
more obvious that it's not from your
opinion so this is what might was Mike
Tyson but a smile on the planet at one
point in his life might I stick to his
own DMS to say listen you and I'm saying
this in context black he means the man
little [__] this [__] ain't real and as
soon as I find the person that started
this meme he knows about the culture
i'ma knock him the [__] out so make sure
it ain't you and this is again probably
a slur burnt roach looking [__] and
when I daughter is happily in a
relationship with a nice-looking man and
she's not interested in an and again
overcooked hot dog like you in context
of Mike Tyson next time you do my
podcast i'ma knock them and this is
again in context Lakoff you it might
take a year because and again in context
you black as [__] get the [__] out of my
DMS before I get your band again in
context black ass deported you guy Cole
is 'red looking [__] Mike Tyson can
really talk [__] he wasn't just a
punchin guy you know I mean he could
actually talk the [__] and then deliver
the knockin I imagine that he typed that
out and then he went and laughed it fits
and yeah send that Oh genuinely I'd love
to have Tyson on the policy yeah but I
think you'd still going though yes you
were thinking about applying don't the
application might I just reiterate this
one thing are you ready to settle down
are you listening out there and this is
advice I think we all should be aware
absolutely leave my Tyson's door
absolutely you know I feel like this is
something that we should be taught at
like schools like there's certain things
you leave a lot coronavirus shop Shane
Dawson's way don't touch the fire my
Tyson's door yeah absolutely well this
is a three gone if anything on you and
religion so you probably have seen this
rental I will call them yeah he's
flocking duvets on what looks like a QVC
type channel everyone said it was
because we love ya this man's been
compared to David Brent let's see I
don't it doesn't benefit me in any way
except I suppose it gets come back
another day and and you know keep the
job for a bit longer make up for all the
other failures you know of gold bridge
about them I don't have to like it you
can make your own mind up or and if you
don't buy it that's not like I'm losing
money
hello it's about being a bit blunt but
the point is I love I swear I don't
swear at this anymore
I don't swear at Madhu Vey I swear by it
brilliant that is brilliant I love him
because this guy I mean everyone knows
that if you're alone and you just have
to keep talking sometimes hard you have
to have a conversation with your soul
yes you're single bridge because
Gorbachev yeah but there's nothing
vicious about this guy alright annually
he is a beautiful human she seems so
lovely and I feel so sorry to gave easy
footed room because I could watch him
yeah well I mean to be what everyone if
you're up for it yeah we'll get this guy
wrong yeah and we'll what I want to
watch him well we're just getting drunk
because he seems like good company no
none of that Porsche Milan stuff no just
a little awesome with some guy a little
bit of whiskey
yep they'll be nice yeah and I would
laugh at him with him with him cause
it's not vicious yeah all night long
yeah I like him and I feel like there
are a lot of vicious people out there
who have comparing his every Brent David
Brent not a nice carriage he's got a lot
of lines but no this guy lelong David
Brody yeah that's the part of the job
because you know is he wants to be loved
yeah he clearly wants to be like them
some of the things he says are he's just
so I'm so sweet he's a wholesome he's so
nice yeah
I want to be his friend someone send us
more footage of this guy he might be my
new favorite person on the Internet ab
city completely agree yeah good guy this
is a light hearted beautiful Oh report
from the folks over ABC Brian who found
out some bad news
somebody's about to get an ABC 13
umbrella who's been going through a
tough time recently so we're gonna go
meet Mary what is an ABC 13 umbrella oh
you need to understand is a beef is ABC
13 it's a local news station and this
guy found out some bad news
for this woman the fire broke out at
Mary's home on Mill Road in clover
Monday night and destroyed almost
everything she held dear well see my
home burning up a new family the light
must hit passed away on her way to my
house her house burned everything in her
house burned it was a fire start we
don't know what an umbrella what a fire
starts well this this of it her daughter
reached out to ABC 13 about her
extraordinary loss and today
chief meteorologist george Flickinger
set out to brighten up her day I thought
the umbrella was symbolic no life is
raining on you at the moon we're here to
give you the umbrella yeah and what that
umbrella symbolizes is a lot of other
things that come with a check for
$50,000 yeah yeah you bought with your
brother and Kush Falls oh yeah exactly
no Brian look you have your own ABC 13
umbrella thank to you just been down you
wrote on the streets you'll need some
shelter thank to you bringing you
sunshine on a rainy day imagine how
annoying this one must be to live with
I'm bringing you sunshine on a rainy day
everything about him is so cliche isn't
it yeah but what about the sunshine Mary
you know you're still thinking about the
burnt down house aren't you no yeah with
this umbrella you've got something
that's much more than a house protection
well it's signed
yeah it's sign and I have never actually
signed one of these before and I'm not
going to be changing that policy for you
Mary
that's the case if you see what we do
here we give umbrellas up we don't pry
it on them yeah see the main issue here
at Jane or whatever the [__] your name
is
I've never actually signed one of these
before because it makes no [__]
difference to a [__] umbrella whether
you sign it or no
you ask because I don't know how to
write do you think the new intro the old
intros better I do because although you
do you never I'm not quite sure about it
I keep it so it's not the audio it's the
visuals are on the bring back the Alden
trophy yeah if possible yeah trying the
KFC the doughnut sandwich this thing
looks pretty good comes with one side I
got wedges and I also added our mac and
cheese cuz I like the mac and cheese
it's gonna try it
that looks disgusting now that's amazing
is that actual glazed doughnut yeah well
not either side of chicken yeah why the
[__] would have doughnut and chicken my
sweet with the the chick is sweetness
with chicken you have what wasn't
checking regularly you dip your chips on
your milk trick for this reason don't
hardly although yeah it's really the
salt but that's yeah I mean look at it
soggy
that's rancid for me that looks amazing
very very messy sandwich and they have
not even one bite of it I hate that
that's that's an instant downgrade for
me do you know when you have burgers and
they're just dropping the bit before you
even put them in your mouth I'm like
what the [__] am I doing here
partly what I want I don't like that
that's just drop in a bit are you
actually look at his face actually goes
for [__] sake look at his eyes so it
drops out on then he goes drops do you
see it just oozing out below it below
then look at his faces realizes facing
oh so far look at surfers they Wow look
see he didn't stop him what a pie isn't
it we wanted to Italian or come on Wow
your sex life there's something about it
there's just extreme self-awareness but
also at the same time such extreme
self-love describe them in a word review
a cuddly a bit mean we'd like the cuddly
yeah I can squeeze them together you and
I have him in the middle to just squeeze
and basically make a similar thing I
have seen ironically he's the meat in
the sandwich then if you want chicken
and Donuts head to your nearest chicken
and donut shop of course a common thing
in the UK but weird over in America if
anyone makes their orden
Twitter saw Instagram it if you haven't
already hit the like button subscribe
also we're doing a lot of content on TG
to the second channel make sure you
subscribe to that as well and we'll see
you later [__]